a consignment of German weapons makes
its way Eastward these are elements of a
patriot missile battery which is being
deployed in Poland they're being sent
there to protect the poles against
malfunctioning Russian rockets that may
miss Targets in Ukraine is
Holland after Slovakia is now our second
area of operations and the training of
ukrainians on the Patriot system is also
running simultaneously therefore it only
makes sense that for the time being this
deployment in Poland will be limited to
six months and then we will have to see
how it will continue in the future
but in Ukraine the need is for tanks
specifically the German manufactured
Leopard 2 main battle tank many analysts
consider it to be the perfect weapon
system for Ukraine which would give it a
material advantage over soviet-era tanks
which make up part of the Russian forces
The Leopard 2 is in the Arsenal of many
EU countries and several have said they
want to give some to the ukrainians but
can't without German permission since
they manufacture the tanks they hold the
re-export rights now Poland says it is
considering sending them to Ukraine even
with no German authorization
we will seek this approval from Germany
but this is a secondary issue even if we
don't get such an approval in the end we
will give our tanks to Ukraine anyway
within a small Coalition of countries
even if Germany isn't in that Coalition
for months The Leopard 2 issue has been
growing in importance in Germany many
politicians from within the Coalition
and without are now arguing in favor of
releasing them including the foreign
minister who told French TV on Sunday if
asked Germany would not stand in the way
until now the weapon systems Germany has
allowed to be deployed to Ukraine have
been predominantly defensive but Maine
battle tanks are mostly offensive
instruments ultimately the decision to
allow german-made tanks to be used
against Russian forces in Ukraine is one
for the chancellor all F shots
Dominic Kane Al Jazeera Berlin